i definitely need to watch kung fu
hustle and confessions
yeah um so have you watched scott
pilgrim
of course yeah i like scott pilgrim i
really like scott paul it's a good movie
yeah i mean
it's a good movie it's a good movie i
think it's a really good movie um i mean
i'm a huge fan of edgar wright edgar
wright's the other director where i'm
just like whatever you make i'll [ __ ]
watch it edgar wright is like the master
of visual comedy yeah
where like he he manages to cut
something in a way or just like edit
something in a way that just makes it
like
whoa that i wasn't expecting out of that
but that's hilarious yeah it's just he's
one of the few
people who whatever genre he takes on he
will put his own spin on the genre yeah
like it's it's so rare to find someone
who you can just watch a movie not
and you can just tell this edgar wright
through the editing itself
because it's such a snappiness yeah it's
just like the unique
and the the snappiness and the like it's
very it's very rhythmic isn't it yeah
yeah yeah
is this your favorite edgar wright film
i think it is i think mine is still
shawn of the dead
because i was debating putting sean of
the dead on hot fuzz
i i like fuzz that's a great movie hot
fuzz is good
i just feel like the first half was like
a little bit boring um that's why
i don't think it's as strong as uh sean
of the dead
um and scott pilgrim i feel like is the
most edgar wright film there is i
feel i feel scott pilgrim couldn't be
made by any other
no no that's that's the thing right i
feel sean of the dead sean penn
uh is that his name yeah sean penn and
uh
nick
i was about to say nick fury then i was
like wait that's that's not nick
frost nick frost nick frost yeah
oh i said sean penn oh sean
is the one that dies every movie i i was
wondering who you're trying
i was like i'm trying to think like when
you said no sean penn is not the one who
dies in every movie yeah sean penn is
the one that always dies in every movie
why is there so many shots sean
right here she was she played uh kevin
spacey's wife in house of cards
i haven't seen a house i haven't seen it
i've seen house of cards okay
but going back to school the reason i
put this on is because like i do do
really really [ __ ] like sean of the
dead um but i feel like scott pilgrim
is just the most edgar wright movie to
exist
at the moment it's him on like his best
form
and i feel like it's this this movie
kind of like
i feel like defined a whole generation
of nerds oh yeah like you
you've seen so many people who just
based their entire [ __ ] personality
on this one movie you know who you are
you know who you [ __ ] are
like you meet you me you meet that
person that like you meet one person of
like that and like every anime
convention you go to
of course yeah it's um but well i mean
i think the reason why it works so well
is because like
again edgar wright's like way of
directing is very like
over exaggerated and like very
non-rooted and that works perfectly with
scott pilgrim because scotland is based
off of [ __ ] comic books
yeah right
like i literally watched his movies like
from the beginning i mean i i watched
spaced before
the day so i'm like i i've known of them
for like a very very long time
of the dead hot fuzz then i can't
remember the third one they made
balls in world's end that's it also i
think hot fuzz is like it's like where i
grew up those kind of towns yeah oh yeah
oh [ __ ] it's very much like if you're
not like
familiar with british like yeah it's
literally just like they ripped my town
oh i noticed they didn't but that's very
much similar to like yeah i feel like
that was the vibe they were going for
that's why hot fuzz like barely made it
big in the u.s because like
you know a lot of the references just
americans i mean i i feel like sean of
the dead and hot fuzz were
both very much cult hits yeah yeah um
because they're very much ingrained in
you know british humor and british
culture you know
you you watch hot fuzz and you probably
can get a vibe of what the place like he
grew up in
which is like nothing that happened to
you yeah yeah it's just like not
something you can say for many other
british films even yeah i mean people
when when people think british films
they or british culture they're like oh
it's like harry potter right
everything's like harry potter over
there everyone's just
wizarding yeah but i think another thing
that's been lost through time
was just how [ __ ] unpopular this was
when this first came out
because now like it's like now it's just
like nerd culture
mainstream nerd culture hi i'm uh i'm a
nerd guys
i identify as a nerd but i remember when
i first saw this um in theaters i saw
this
by myself in a completely empty theater
in brighton right wow really because
nobody wanted to see
this [ __ ] movie nobody is it a
marketing issue huh was it a marketing
issue
maybe maybe the nerds just didn't want
to expose themselves right
except it's like [ __ ] you dude normally
you know it's normally a marketing issue
especially if it's a good movie
i mean this movie this movie [ __ ]
bombed in the cinemas
it was it was only afterwards definitely
definitely cult yeah it definitely
became a cult movie that got picked up
and more people watched as like
nerd culture became more mainstream but
i remember the first time watching this
it blew my
[ __ ] mind how good this was and i
couldn't tell anyone about it because
nobody was interested in watching it
like how did you watch it yeah just how
do i how did i sell this
how did you sell this to someone yeah
like go back go back 20 years how do you
sell this to someone to like one of your
mates or something
which tom is really good and you want to
watch it again
just like what's it like what's like
tell me i'll i'll just take you just
shut up
shut up and i'll take you don't expect
anything buy some popcorn have a good
time
is it like the three it's like the food
off